so one thing that we spent a lot of time
thinking about is this idea that you
know you can own four types of assets
right stocks bonds currencies
commodities and in this digital world
there should be digital stocks bonds
cars yeah bond is right and so Bitcoin
being probably the most attractive asset
to date right in the currency bucket
yeah and over time as these other assets
or digital assets get introduced
how does Wall Street interact with that
right because I think to your point
they're more evolutionary than
revolutionary yes how how do you you
know see this playing out and shouldn't
frankly the crypto community trust Wall
Street
well that latter question is as a whole
a whole can of worms but how I think
this is gonna play out is look we all
understand that digitally natively
digital assets can can trade and settle
instantly and or or in near-real-time
the technologists would correct me but
but but but a lot faster than then the t
plus two days trade date plus two days
settlement that we have now on Wall
Street and it's going to cut out a lot
of the intermediaries that take cuts and
create counterparty risk where it
otherwise would not exist yep so I
actually think very much that the that
the ICO craze a lot of folks are
thinking that there's there's a lot of
scams and of course there are but
there's something really important from
a corporate finance perspective that
comes out of that which is that
investors are rationally in my opinion
willing to give up the traditional
covenants and preferences that they
usually are used to getting in
investments in exchange for not having
to deal with this crazy clearing trading
clearing and settlement infrastructure
on Wall Street which exposes them to all
kinds of risks that they just don't need
to be exposed to so they get instant
settlement with no counterparty risk if
they are trading these these utility
tokens or security tokens how much of
that is driven by human greed and just
the idea that
price will appreciate and so a lot of it
right okay so talk to me about do you
think that investors are actually making
a rational trade-off in terms of hey I
actually don't like that you know
settlement system and so therefore I'm
willing to give up or do you think some
of it is human greed and by proxy that's
what the trade-offs that they're making
I think it's I think it's the latter I'm
not sure that that a lot of folks are
necessarily going through that thought
process that we just talked about they
instinctively understand that they
outright own this asset it's not an IOU
from anyone and therefore I'd rather own
that it's real property it's it's
something that I can that I can maintain
on my own and and and if my Broker
Dealer goes bust I'm not stuck as a as
an unsecured creditor to a leveraged
institution like the customers of MF
Global or Lehman Brothers work that's
right where they end up taking a haircut
right so I think a lot of people do
intuitively understand that how are they
actually rationally making a mobility
and a loss severity to broker-dealer
default when they buy securities
probably not but I but again a you know
the wisdoms of Kratt wisdom of crowds
right there there it is intuitive and I
also do believe that this market has
shown that the crowdfunding rules and
the JOBS Act that Congress passed to
help make crowdfunding a lot easier they
failed and they failed because of the
bureaucracy involved in raising capital
so what this market I think is doing is
pushing
I hope they policymakers towards let's
actually have a JOBS Act to that that
actually tears down even more of those
bureaucratic barriers because it's
pretty clear that there is something
special here in the structure of these
icos and let's actually help clarify the
regulation so far the SEC has not been
friendly to that but there are the folks
on Congress who are